[Musique]
de ce qu'il faudrait mais je pense qu'on
avance petit à petit j'espère il y a
beaucoup de métiers dans lesquels les
femmes et les hommes ne sont pas ne
partent pas sur la même ligne de départ
elles sont pas égalité au départ quand
c'est pas c'est qu'on voit si le plan
salarial sur beaucoup de choses c'est
important qu'il y a l'égalité
homme-femme pour que chacun se sente
bien que qu'il y a le vivant ensemble
moi je suis un peu surpris de voir qu'il
y a certains métiers qui sont capturés
par soit des hommes soit des femmes et
on envisage pas que ça puisse être fait
par d'autres sexes
moi ce que je connais on va dire au
niveau professionnel je pense qu'il y a
toujours des inégalités qui persistent
notamment en termes de salaire surtout
si je sais que l'entreprise dans
laquelle je suis fait un effort pour
essayer de rétablir l'égalité on est
toujours bien en dessous quand même
dans le monde je pense que c'est très
très différent en fonction des pays
je pense à l'Arabie Saoudite c'est payer
un petit peu les droits des femmes sont
un peu remis en cause sont complètement
remis en cause alors dans le monde je
pense qu'il y a encore des grosses
inégalités qui persistent surtout dans
certains pays où on voit que les femmes
aujourd'hui ou encore très peu de droits
on voit avec les différentes
manifestations qui a eu si on pense par
exemple à l'Iran ou qu'il y a encore
beaucoup de travail à faire
[Musique]